my main man Lee syat has read with his
little [__] uh Suge Knight shirt on
his forehead is matching the redness
well you just gave me like you just put
all I didn't even I see the mistake I
make is is a taking things from you and
B you're like the master you like plays
the Alpha Brain bottle so I couldn't see
how much hash you put in there you put
like the whole chunk of hash
the problem with this hash was this used
to be wax
so I didn't have any place to put this
Lebanese in here so I put in this wax
thing
and the wax absorbed the hash absorbed
the wax this is death people are telling
me this [__] recipe right here
started by the bottom now we're here
what the [__]
Thursday night the 8th of September
Jerry larocha making it happen what's
happening got his new [__] special
coming out on fuse TV yeah
the fortune cookie
you wouldn't need a fortune cookie it's
a joke Lee yeah it's everything this
[__] guy me and him were Partners in
all the Chinese buffets it was the best
that's all that's all we do [__] wake
up go again anytime we'd work we'd
always he'd tell me there's a Chinese
place they don't have them out here I
love Chinese food buffets they don't
have them is there one I don't know
these people too healthy yeah it's a
problem that's the problem that's too
healthy they never [__] do it they're
too Texas has some wild ass [__] do
Texas can have there's a place in Texas
called uh either Alibaba or Tara one of
the same owners it's Middle Eastern food
buffet they have buffets for everything
and it's the [__] best [__] the best
hummus you'll ever have the best let's
stop right there all right don't come on
the shelter Bahamas
you show up looking like London after
you came back from India with bracelets
and [__] turbans on your head now you
want to [__] insult me in the Middle
Eastern
unbelievable no that's the best did you
have them when you were growing up are
they new because
it was amazing there's some oh it's a
great one I never heard of a Chinese
buffet till 19
79. somebody told me that the mai tai on
Kennedy Boulevard was a Chinese buffet
and that they put the ribs up
and I went there one time and it was
[__] brilliant oh man and I kept
going back then the thing was to go
there before the giant came like that
was right insane people were going to
other bars me and this little crowd
which even if we didn't go to Giant game
we'd meet that because somebody always
going to the Giant game and it was kind
of empty it was close to a church but
everybody would go to the other who the
[__] wants to eat Polynesian food on
Sunday at 11 30. me I do yeah that
sounds great yeah
having one of the funniest times I know
my friend Timmy listens to this it was
with his brother and I've said this
story on the podcast I mean we you know
you start going to the pump when you're
[__] 15 and you're going to a
Polynesian Chinese place you go in there
you get high and you bust away this ball
they [__] hate us they [__] hate
it they [__] hate us what did you do
to them everything you could imagine I
remember one time we picked up the tray
of spare ribs they're like why are we
gonna walk back and forth this is a
waste of time we're gonna kill these
things because that mistake was they
took really good sparrows and cut them
in half look the big bone ends
and they may cut them in half so you
have to eat 52 of them they got 26 of
them you know what I'm saying I would
eat 20 [__] nine of them in those
days I didn't give a [__] about my heart
I'm doing blow three days I see a stack
of ribs they're going down rice that
everything all that Polynesians it's
Chinese Polynesians same [__] you know
they have all the [__] uh things with
the red sauces which I stay the [__]
away from me too I avoid that [__]
you know like that [__] you dip in like
the people get that fried stuff oh yeah
something is that what they brought me
at that Chinese food place went to at
the South Point like it was it wasn't
Duck Sauce it was supposed to be like
Duck Sauce
if you're out of New York yeah if you're
out of New York New Jersey or Boston you
never want a duck shot that's it they're
not going to give it to you okay out
here okay I thought you were saying you
can't order what they think Duck Sauce
is completely different things it's a
complete [__] different thing the
worst one for me is the mustard there's
almost no places you can go yeah they
have the packages yeah
but listen you're gonna put mustard on
the [__] dumpling or a spare
ribs
Golden Chopsticks is all right down
there in North Hollywood right there by
me I went in there one night
it was okay yeah I don't even know what
to get what do you get there I always
get the chicken broccoli with the
chicken fried rice combo it's true
that's really really good stuff you live
down by there yeah well I live right on
the corner yeah because I live down
right there too there's one I like I
haven't been to Golden Chopsticks but
there's one called China Light China
Lights is good yeah
that's one by your house
yeah the Cuban places right it's even
worse is it really oh you know what's
good though is that Taya Thai which is
right there I went there Ty's really
good and then noodle monster is pretty
[__] good too
it's Chinese and uh Vietnamese and Thai
it's like a fusion but it's good it's
all right it's okay there's some I ain't
walking in there it's too many countries
you know what's good look at that that
sushi place is [__] great Maya Sushi
or whatever that's good [__] there
that's I that's the
he gave me Edibles once that were
stronger than anything I'd ever had and
I puked on that but I made the mistake
of telling him that I had sushi for
dinner so now he calls that sushi place
what is it wholesale Sushi and I haven't
been able to go in I haven't been able
to go in since it's been like eight
months so good but now I just associated
with people
that was the last time I was in Vegas I
was like I hate being like on the Strip
after enough times I'm like so I went
just walking to this Chinese food
restaurant that was like um like I don't
know a little bit outside the strip it
was the weirdest place I've ever been
through they just had trays that were
filled with food that they would just
circle around the whole restaurant and
it got packed then dim some right yeah
you could just pick like I want that one
then let me get that one let me get some
of that like it was all kinds of
different [__] away from like normal
[__] to like chicken chow mein to like
this weird squid [__] like it was they
just it was just constant it was like a
[__] train like family stuff yeah
dude it was badass that was nice that
was really good there's some really
great you know I mean whatever you're
into this right
I I feel that Texas like even when we
used to tour early on I'm talking I know
you 15 years yeah man since 2000 no
problem two thousand El Paso wow I
remember you didn't let me go home too
because remember I wanted to drive I
want to go home early that Sunday
morning or whenever Monday morning and
you we both were staying a little bit
longer and uh a Pink Floyd documentary
came on VH1 and you're like where are
you going sit down like you're not going
anywhere we're gonna watch this remember
that that was great man yeah that was
God that was that was too that was when
the old the second Club he had remember
that with the giant elevated stage
that's where that that's where we were
that's it was that across the street
from the old yes I started in the old
one that was the one I really enjoyed
yeah I heard that was everyone said that
was still the best that was still the
best yeah have you been to his new Club
Once yeah yeah where's the new one when
was the last time you were there I went
to the one that's kind of near the
airport like in the middle of town kind
of like I did that where he'd with the
other guy helped him open it that other
comedian or whatever forgot the guy's
name but like that's the one it's uh
[__] it's a kind of nearly Trevino you
just take it it's right there and it's
up the street kind of the airport I
don't know if he's moved it again but I
think that was do you believe you shot
your first special
it's so weird who shot the special Gabe
Gabe produced it we went up to uh Levity
Live at Club in Nyack up there and
um yeah he packed it out because he you
know he put his name all over which is
such a huge help you know and so we just
packed the place out with like a real
crowd you know it was really awesome and
yeah he just let me run he goes dude do
your time dude just because we need at
least an hour I end up doing like about
an hour and 20 so we'll see it was it
was really fun you know when you knew a
comic
people at home
you know think you have an agent and a
manager and you have all that stupidity
but I gotta tell you guys sixty percent
of the time it's another comic no
questions no question and it's uh
it's a really nice Bond yeah people say
comedy is clicky and it is very clear
and you have to accept that but the
clicks that up what's the matter lead no
I just I I that annoys me because
offices are clicky this is just your
office everywhere well everything is
clicky yeah for sure but like but what
fascinates me is when you have comic you
know that right that most of the help
you're going to get is from another
comedian so why do you have Comics that
are [__] I never understand that
it's like dude why are you sitting here
burning every [__] bridge when you
know that you know the 90 of your help
is going to come from your own peers
right so why would you be such a prick
to everybody I never understood that I
never got that you know I never got it
either it's so weird I never got it
either I I
assume it's like a jealousy Factor it
mixed with a little hatred like you
confuse hatred with jealousy yeah yeah
that could happen it's amazing how
something shows up disguised as
something else
uh
I don't know it's just a lot of things
but I'm happy that
you know Joe's helped me a lot I don't
sound like you know Nick Swanson we saw
Nick at the thing the other day you know
you have all these people from different
walks and then you have different people
that have an opportunity to help you or
something and they don't I don't want
Comics to listen to this going well what
do I do latch on to a comic no no no no
it's not like no no no no no no no no no
no that's actually a turn off you know I
was talking to a guy last week the guy I
worked in Toledo Bo Boat City opened up
for uh
uh what's his name the
the really educated black dude that's on
the road always on
HBO I'm sure DL yeah and D L told them
now when I'm on the East Coast you're
working with me right and he goes you
know two guys help me Chappelle and D.L
Hughley you know it's we work together
they dig you
and uh and I think everybody I work with
on the road I I tell them if you come to
La you know look me up there you know
nothing nothing we could do for you
right right that's what Comics get to
miss this is the misnomer though we're
saying Comics could help you but there's
nothing a comic could do for you right
there's a different levels in your
career where a comic could come in and
go hey come on the road
right and from there you take off and
everybody I know you know from Josh Wolf
went on the river live with a cable guy
you know Chelsea used to open up a David
towel yeah you hear these stories so I I
never want people to think you you have
to put the work in you do yeah and
eventually somebody will pick you up and
go listen are you a regular at the store
you're not let me call down there for
you at least get you a show yeah man
it's the people who come out and they're
here for one day and go hey I'm here
what can you do for me I can't do
nothing no that's you don't have to go
out for a couple months get yourself a
little name get the store to pull you
and then I'll give you the push you need
right you're following me it's like when
you're up over the hill and all of a
sudden you're like [__] I'm not gonna
make it and three Puerto Ricans show up
and push you over that's what this is we
just give you a little push after you've
done the work yeah that's probably the
easiest way to say it a lot of people
show up and it's like oh remember that
one time you know I'm here and I'm like
okay well you want to go have lunch and
we can hang out for a little bit but
that's all that really can happen you
know and that goes a long way sometimes
too A lot of people don't understand
like it's it's nice to just be able to
you know when you first come to a town I
didn't want anyone to help me it was
just nice to go see somebody I knew for
an hour you know what I mean and go have
lunch go you know relax that was great
yeah you can't like what can we do right
now like it's out here it's like [__]
man it's you know again it's like
nobody's gonna take a chance on somebody
who's never heard of no matter who's
plugging them no matter who's you know
they just don't have time for that out
here that's uh that's the thing but even
if you could like at most you could like
book a room but even let's say you
introduce them to an agent and let's say
they start booking them everywhere
for Comics it even if you get booked it
doesn't mean you're going to be funny
like you can't it's I mean there's so
much you have to do that's why it's like
yeah like it a lot of guys don't
understand they'll have a friend who
hits right you've seen that happen too
where someone from you know some guy
from Houston has a friend who just got a
deal or a show so they'll come out here
and think oh okay I'm I'm next right and
it's like no dude like you know it's you
have to yeah they just want to get lazy
and just wait you know it's like you
can't do that like you know it yeah like
you said you don't want anyone to get
the idea that you have to latch on to
anybody you shouldn't do that because a
lot of comics can kind of smell that
they can kind of smell the they do they
they smell that they want to guess send
and hey man you know if you ever want to
take somebody on the road I live in L.A
I live in LA I got 90 guys in front of
me that need work I just met you
the other partner right there that I
just met you yeah I have 90 guys in
front of me do what you're doing
you know do what the [__] you're doing
keep doing what you're doing and you're
ready I'm here yeah man you know someday
you come out to the store but you know
our friend came out from uh Paducah
George nice Spanish kid that I worked
with in Paducah and he sent me an email
I told him I said listen bro here's the
deal you got to go out now
and make a name amongst the comics yeah
I mean you got to hit all these [__]
dumbass rooms yeah all these shitty
[__] rooms and then somebody's gonna
see you and go boom we're gonna get you
in spite of the Improv and it becomes
infectious yeah now you get a manager
now he calls the Laugh Factory now you
call me I could recommend you because
they want somebody with a [__]
manager you know it's become a bit this
has become like an industry show now
yeah I grandfathered my way in but a lot
of these guys they want you to have a
manager and they want you to have an
agent they want you to have a booking
agent no booking agent is going to sign
you when you're making 500 a week no
that's 50 a [__] a week from you and
you gotta turn on the lights I love it
when features go I need a booking age
it's great the booking agent is you
working with a headliner yeah him
booking you and then you and getting
introduced to the clubs giving them your
best 20 minutes and let them bring you
back the headline on Wednesday and
Sunday next time you come back with the
other line and the next time you do it
again next time you do it again now they
give you Fourth of July it's a dead
weekend but at least you got a [__]
weekend and you're on your way now
you're gonna on Twitter now you're gonna
go to [__] Facebook it's the same
thing it's the same work process you
know started from the bottom now we're
here what the [__] Thursday night [__]
suck you gotta keep working today that's
the thing man a lot of people don't it's
comedy is one of those places where like
how do I it's almost like where people
move out here and it's like it's okay
it's like if I got a letter
from a loan company saying I've been
pre-approved for a ten thousand dollar
loan and I lose my [__] and I'm like I
did it that's how they act too when they
move out here they act like they just
got a letter in the mail saying they've
been pre-approved for a loan and they're
like well here I am give me the loan and
they're like no actually it's not like
that you know like that's they don't
read the fine prints if you did the
Chicago Comedy Festival right and Dave
Becky walked up for you from three yards
right and he gives you a card and he
goes as soon as you get to L.A call me
then you [__] do it then you move
Manana like there's no you go right to
Grandpa and you go to saving bonds gotta
go let's cash the [__] in
because I need to train to La
[__] there's different
situations yeah and I when I when I talk
about comedy I don't want to alienate
people a lot of people listen to this in
their cubicles I have to say any art
and he was telling me that now he trains
people oh yeah wow you did you were
saying that I bumped into him I had to
go get Mercy I mean my wife are coming
home like and I told him you play a
lottery today
let's play a pick six right and went to
that liquor store and some guy came out
and I recognized my neighbor and we
started talking and I go was that you
one still perform he told me his whole
career how long he's been doing it like
he had to travel for eight years and
sleep on the couch Jesus it's work it's
everything this is work this is work and
those couch stories and the floor
stories and working at a at Dallas
hyenas and going to the supermarket and
the next one opening up your [__]
eggs and there's a roach in there that
broke in through the [__] bat through
the package you know in those condos and
great when I was sleeping on the floor
with no shirt on and next thing you know
you hear a bunch of people dialing and
you go into your living room and they
got a telemarketing [__] chapter of
comedy clubs in your [__] living room
these are all true stories dude have you
my favorite road moments were now
looking back when it was happening I
thought I was gonna die
you've done this I'm sure a million
times when you first started as a
feature right do you remember when you
would work those weeks with those 20
something years in bitter Road guys we
lived in the midwest the world
and they sell everything yes so sneakers
buttons shoes
guitars and they're bitter about La
every little in L.A you suck dick you
might as well start because nothing's
gonna happen to you dude it's funny on
my special I have a bit about that where
I talk about when my CD came out
someone's like hey whose dick did you
have to suck I'm like the one you didn't
that's who's Dick you know what I mean
and then I was like and
what does that even mean like what what
if there was some magic dick out there
would you suck it [__] no you know what
I mean like you would just you know what
I mean like you have to like first of
all I'm not good at I'm I'm tell promise
you right now I'd be horrible at sucking
dick so if I were to go blow some guy to
move ahead he'd be like nah I'm sorry
man like you're not good at this yeah
that's when they pick yeah
don't worry about the rim job right so
at like as headliners
what would you look for since there are
so many people who could feature for you
like what do you guys look for if you
get to pick a feature it doesn't matter
just someone's funny like you did funny
and you was fine and you could tell them
yeah but there's like yeah
I know that he's striving right I want
to know that he's paying a rent I want
to know that he's banging it out every
[__] night like I did yep I want to
know that he's not right well I'm tired
there's no tithe in this I don't know
what you're talking about right until
you pop three or four things you can't
be tired
I don't know what wedding you're talking
about Christmas suck my dick Jesus was a
Jew you know let's get it together too
many times and you've been through this
I mean dude there is nothing that like
if and I'll tell you that's what that's
what you just said it best like I would
look for a comic who I know this guy has
spent at least two or three already
Christmases alone in a [__] hotel
room in the middle of nowhere because
they're working that week you know and
we've done that dude I remember that
dude those those are nightmare espec
when you're up like in the North and
it's just [__] snow note in there's
nothing to do there's no show that night
and you're just trapped in your room on
Christmas like there's always somebody
who goes hey man what are you gonna do
you want to come over to the house yeah
yeah something yep there's oh there's
this manager at the club one of the
other Comics really learned about human
compassion yeah on the road sometimes
yeah you know speaking about El Paso I
used to have the gay manager
young Mexican lover and dude he was a
bad man he was like bad [__]
John dude he was a bad mother and you
hugged him and kissed him and I'd
squeeze his ass and he'd run from me you
know I mean it was just [__] you meet
I could write a book of the people that
I met yeah that bailed me on the spot
that's a feature I am that I wish
there's a way I could get a hold of him
and thank him because there was millions
of them there was a Puerto Rican guy in
South Dakota one time like Green River
South Dakota where I'll never forget
that stuck his head out when he heard
the accent
stuck his head out the window and he
goes bro I met some white chair I stuck
out of here in the service I'm the only
Puerto Rican around here and I'm like we
can can we get weed right you know and
he brought me weed and he didn't charge
me when I did a triple run one time
[__] Minneapolis Minnesota or not
even Minneapolis I'm sorry like
Minnesota all the way where they fish
for the ice yeah yeah yeah yeah and all
that [__] and we'd finished the show
dog we drive we drove for two hours in
the darkness yeah and all there was was
fake deer and how you the light was when
your uh headlights Hit the Lights I mean
you were skip Lee you kept going Joey
like where are you taking me
I've had a tire blowout on a turbo one
run time driving through Montana I hit
black ice my car spun my tire exploded
I'll never forget this I'd [__] pull
over Jack it up put on the little tiny
spare and I still had 50 miles to go and
I just made it to the gig like those are
those triple runs like that are like
[__] man have you ever had a triple run
during good weather I don't think that
exists right
yeah I mean man we would just go in like
death I mean you know it's not that you
would go it's that you didn't think
about it yeah man you loved the comedy
so much you loved and you'd go to your
friends and go I'm doing potato run two
next week and they go in December good
luck good luck we'll never see you again
and even it's not like when you're like
oh you're flying to Boston good luck
those planes go down
let me tell you something you will hit a
deer
yeah
ties blow out you got to get out put
chains on your car you ever had a you
ever run out of gas on a turbo run and
you have to go [__] run like a mile
to a gas station fill it up run back to
the that's happened to me like Dude
triple runs oh man it's it's it's it's
it's nothing else can come that is
you'll never run is a training program
once you call David trible as a comic
and he goes I have six weeks of work for
you you know one thing you you go in a
comedy Camp yeah man you're learning
every aspect of comedy except marketing
there's no really marketing because it's
too quick it's too quick it's too quick
one night you're done what you learn is
how to drive get there live on 50 bucks
yeah you know get to the gig directions
what to put in your car you know by the
second year of Comedy your car becomes
your home it's a a dollar store yeah
that's the best way I could describe you
have screwdrivers anti-freeze anything
you know a soda a football a frisbee you
like MacGyver I mean a knife a wrench a
[__] soccer ball a sleeping bag a
tent a grill you've got Tang you've got
Waters in the back you've got so much
[__] in your car and you learn how to
put it all together yeah you learn how
to uh pull over and sleep for three
hours yeah leave the windows opening the
car running and lock the doorknobs open
up the sunroof at those rest areas you
know what I would do with the rest areas
I would I would sleep I would take uh I
had a water gun and I would just hold it
and I'd wear a hoodie and I'd bought I
bought a water gun and I would put it in
the middle pocket so it looked like I
was holding a gun when I would when you
go like to the Shady really creepy
[__] you know just in case just make
it look like I'm packing you know like
you would do all dude I remember when I
was on the road the best feeling was one
time I was doing a gig and I was in
between gigs I just found a basketball
Court out in the middle of nowhere and I
had my basketball in my car
this is the [__] [__] basketball
swimming trunks oh yeah cause you don't
know what you're gonna bump into and on
the triple run see the weekends on
Saturday
so the week doesn't start till Tuesday
you're on Montana with you by yourself
okay let's explain the lead to the
breakdown on payments okay let's say
let's say you're because I I would
feature I'm trying to watch so let's say
you do a comedy club and they give you
500 bucks Wednesday through Sunday or
whatever 700 bucks you would get about
the same with the triple gig except they
would pay you each night and what was
mind-blowing is the first night you got
ten dollars and then you would go to the
second Club you get 35 and then the
middle the third one you get 250 and
then the next night you get 75 and
they're like it would all even out at
the end but like you said a lot of times
you do those gigs you have zero in your
pocket and you get to the first gig and
all you get is 10 bucks like [__] I
gotta stretch this for all day tomorrow
veggie and cheese dude Subway [__] yeah
after breakfast the other half for lunch
box yeah hopefully they'll feed me I
think that's it yep and then you get the
hotel you check in and they have like a
buffet downstairs like a free uh
Gatherings of the test and they got like
the little pizzas and you go down there
and eat two of them but you're like you
know what I'm [__] starving starving
I mean this whole there's always
something I didn't have a credit card so
they would say you can't yeah me too
dude you can't turn the TV on you can't
turn the phone on Lee a [__]
nightmare when you don't have it but
then you know what happens is then
there's that always those weird magic
moments where like the one hot chick in
that one town comes to the show and you
got a room for the night you know what I
mean remember those those weird moments
like what is she even doing [__] me
but I'll take it you know and it's just
it's all that like oh it just you're
almost in a you know like you said you
meet these and you build these weird
it's almost like you're living a life
with somebody for one night but for
whatever reason all the emotions and all
that [__] they're just it's all cool and
it's like it's nice it's it's those
nothing can compare to any any comedian
who's just starting off if you want to
learn how to be a comic go do a triple
run right now just [__] pack up your
car and go to a triple run and you'll be
you will be a better comic when it's
over you will oh my God you learn
quickly okay so I was doing a gig I'm
doing a travel run one time in Montana
and this it was I was in Dallas and it
was before it was going to take off now
when I first started doing triple runs
dude you think you're a superstar you're
like oh my God I'm gonna go tour and
like this is you know and you don't
realize it you know like Pocatello Idaho
isn't you know the entertainment capital
of the world but you're like [__] I'm
gonna be doing it like you know and so
you do these um and so anyway this tape
started circulating from this comedian I
forgot his name but he's on stage and I
was I was going to be at the club in two
nights and I remember the VHS popping in
and this guy's on stage for whatever
reason he was taping at a triple one
which is already a mistake you're not
gonna get your Tonight Show you're not
gonna get your Tonight Show submission
so he's and he's sitting there and he's
in Montana and he's a little dude you
know he's not a big guy someone's
heckling him and he's just finally after
like 30 minutes he just lays into the
guy and he goes this is my [__] life
and you sit there and then you just see
this [__] corn-fed redneck just get
up and just walk to the stage he gr
pushes the comic unplugs the mic and
then boom knocks the [__] out of him and
then like a brawl just starts and it's
all on tape and you're like and you're
gonna be at that club in for two nights
and it's like well hope it goes better
for me yes triple runs there's people
who just go out to Heckle the town yeah
oh okay that's it that's all they do
they just go out the heck of the
comically
a lot of times
especially in places like that dude
these are people who are like all the
stress of their week their month their
life they get to just once a week go
take it out on these [__] schmoes who
just walk in and do comedy and they just
[__] it's it's it you can't explain
it to me in Idaho and I had to fight
them dude the following week I hit them
with Chinese food with them all of
course do you think people who do that
know they're terrible people no they
don't they have no idea
trying to get them out of this [__]
New Yorker that I'm funny than he is
they don't they don't they don't realize
they're being [__] they think
they're being part of the show they
think you know one time it was in
Montana Always in Montana dude and I was
doing a show and of course I'm Mexican
but when you met me you're like there's
no [__] way you know nobody believes
it they all think I'm Jewish right
because I you know you look Jewish I
know I look Sephardic dude it's crazy
but like so I um I'm doing this show and
all I say is I'm Mexican
five minutes in I guess I saw a Mexican
and this woman in the back hey
[__] don't you run your [__]
mouth but that I'm [__] Mexican I
don't want to hear no [__] [__]
I'm like whoa I said I'm we're cool all
I said was I was Mexican you know I
didn't wasn't making fun of Mexicans I
was just getting it out there but I'm
Mexican and I said is anyone else here
that's maxing besides me and that stupid
piece of [__] in the back and then dude
she gets on a phone the bar had a
[__] old school phone on it and we're
in the hotel because it was one remember
some of those triple rooms you're in a
lounge of a hotel right like a Red Rock
right yeah I found all that [__] I think
I saw one then in like new Upstate New
York or something oh you probably oh
yeah they're everywhere they're
everywhere and then so she gets on this
phone and throughout I'm doing you know
what 20 minutes I'm featuring and she
gets on the phone and about 10 minutes
after she's been on the phone there's we
aren't we are no longer the only two
Mexicans in Helena Montana there was
like 15 dudes come walking and they're
waiting for me they were waiting they're
all like okay bro what you got the test
cover on we're gonna see what the [__]
happened like and I was like okay here
we go and I'm thinking in my head like
[__] I'm gonna die like this is it like
[__] they're gonna [__] kill me
because she called all of her boys and
they all showed up to kick my ass I
didn't even make if I just you know I
didn't even really make fun of her and
then I said guys uh when I ended my set
I couldn't ego comedian ego I said hey
um by the way if anyone was offended
tonight during my set I apologize uh but
if the only one was offended was that
stupid piece of [__] in the back of the
room then [__] you I'm glad I offended
and then everyone was into it and these
guys are like ready to jump the stage
and what they didn't realize so they're
all staged left were the entrance to the
lounge is right what they didn't realize
was stage right is another door that
just comes right to the hotel so I just
bring up the headline I go thank you
good night and bloop I just go out the
[__] door and I ran to my [__]
room and just hold up I was like man
[__] is that it was it was CR and I was
ready to go in I was like well I guess
I'm gonna die but the headliner grabbed
me so I was bringing up he goes go stage
right he's shaking my hand he goes I'll
get your money go stage right there's
nobody there they don't know that that's
and just go to your [__] room it's
only [__] so I run up to my room when I
get to my room it takes like 30 seconds
right to get to my hotel room the
phone's ringing I pick it up and is this
the front desk there's a gentleman here
who says he went to high school he wants
to know what room you're into and come
up and say hi I'm like no I don't know
anybody in this town like it was and I
remember that I left my car in the
parking lot and it had Texas plates on
it and I talked about being from Texas
and it was the only one with Texas
plates so I did like [__] mission
impossible I had to [__] sneak all
the way down get in my car go park it in
a bank across the street and then sneak
all the way back up I was left the room
[__] take the car with anything on
fire one time I had a scare in Idaho
I had a scare and it was [__] crazy
because I'm on stage and I see this
black guy and he's talking to white
women in Idaho and when I'm cracking
jokes I'm saying to myself this guy's
got the biggest balls because this is
around the OJ time oh man fireman had a
house in Idaho so in my mind I'm like so
after the show I [__] around and I get
off stage and
I talked to the black guy he comes on me
goes brother thank you that you came he
was the only black guy and he was
slinging big dick and you could tell
these white guys hate
like they [__] hate them and when I
went to the bathroom a guy was in there
and he goes did you have a good time
with your negro buddy wow and I could
tell I'm telling you you know listen you
want to [__] piss people off [__]
with their women oh even if they're not
[__] them it's like office in the
gentleman when no question when they
come into the bar the guys chase him out
of the bar and want to fight them just
because they were talking to the girl
the dog it's it's really weird it's a
weird mentality and they're not coming
into our town with that Led Zeppelin
shirt on you know and they [__] go
nuts Lee it's at that what's that Bob
Seger song Turn the Page yeah every
every performer who's ever had to do
one-nighters has lived every moment of
that song right you remember that
they'll walk into the restaurant and
everyone's looking at you like what
[__] freak is this remember Montana
with Rico oh wow Rico you know what I'm
talking about yeah yeah yeah black
Rico's 400 pound black guy with a spider
on his face a [__] a a beard and I'll
never forget
um were you guys a big hit that week
it was horrendous we were co-headlining
in trouble
I'll never forget we want where we were
the first night
and the morning he woke up and there's
no black people for [__] days this
[__] idiot decides to get on the
hands and knees he's Muslim or whatever
the [__] those people out that breathe
and they pray on their knees yeah this
restaurant's packed with white people in
a restaurant he wants to get down and I
told him I go Rico you got to get up
we're going to get killed it's bad
enough you're [__] black and 400
[__] pounds you want to pray though
that's a spider tattoo yeah in 1995.
they don't know nothing about Allah
nothing praying to Allah
he's looking at me like you insulted me
dog I ain't got time for this [__] get
up we're in a Cracker Barrel they're
gonna [__] kill us I sit there
sometimes I never forget when I first
left Denver
I was meeting when I left
Boulder uh June 30th and 95 or whatever
for June 1st I was meeting Carol the
strip in Seattle
and I don't know about you guys I
couldn't wait to [__] tear Carol up
like it was Tuesday and I was jerking
off eight times in the shower just
thinking about how hot a [__] was she
was in a strip for me and I was crazy I
remember I did
Wednesday I'll never forget this
Wednesday Thursday Friday Saturday with
a guy that was from Orange County okay
he was a comedian at the time he said he
owned the house and he had lived out
here for 15 years and
he got from time to time he was an extra
and uh I asked him if he got spots at
The Improv and he goes no and you'll
never get in there and the Laugh Factory
is impossible comedy store and I mean
he's telling me all this [__] and I'll
never forget how negative he was oh but
he gave me a card
and it was four days because I was
telling him I was moving to Seattle
to hook up with this girl and I'm going
to do comedy and he's like you know what
man I don't mean to piss on your parade
but
stay in Seattle don't let people talk
like you're talking and let you talk
them into moving to I still remember
there was a [__] guy with new Chucks
on the road right they used to bring him
up on stage that would drove me crazy
for a couple nights I know I could ride
them out like 10 guys I'm not remember
their names but it's funny that the
triple room see I started on a triple
run yeah me too no no no how is the
house MC oh [__] I'm a triple run that's
how I met Stanhope and a lot of that's
the best you know at that time there
were medium level Comics yeah I don't I
only remember two now that are still in
the business that came through there
there was one kid from San Francisco
that came one time
two-year anniversary and I gotta tell
you guys he blew up that [__] room
nice and I saw him out here at Ralphs
one day and I walked up to him maybe
so two it's 2 15. yeah I think I saw him
after Mad TV okay Mad TV and I did
something else
by 2003 I think I had Mad TV yeah or
I had a few I had like basketball and a
pilot
no ego I knew I was very lucky I knew
that I I thought like I had stepped in
[__] it'll never happen again and I
bumped into him and I walked outside and
went after him like I don't know if you
remember me man
in 1990 [__] two you destroyed the
broker and he goes yeah
and I go what do you do now and he goes
I got out of Comedy completely
I moved on him I did one and it's one of
those times where there was a couple
Comics that I remember going wow that
guy's really good he was one of those
guys yeah Stanhope I saw Stanhope with
the as a feature act like the Bro wow
1991. wow I invite him to stay over the
house he stayed over the house because I
was divorced yeah and I had this huge
house with the comics were cool in those
days it was broke Boulder on Tuesday
okay Craig on Thursday oh Craig wow yeah
Craig which was Dave I'll never forget
the itinerary for Craig Craig was a
triple run
sat Friday was Gunnison yeah Gunnison
and Sunday was no no oh Colorado and
Sunday was
Colorado Springs Colorado Springs like a
barn yeah yeah like something wasn't
Judy Brown's room it was no no it was a
triple run yeah yeah yeah
so what you did was basically what these
poor bastards did was some of them got
up
Wednesday morning after a hard night at
the broker and they'd shoot up to Craig
because it was six hours yeah in Aspen
and that's the thing with a triple run
dude you finish it you finished finish
Wednesday night at 10 you have to be
almost 10 hours across the state
Thursday night like it's there's no joke
there's no joke so sometimes you gotta
drive eight hours some days you drive 45
minutes you have the whole day to
yourself but there's some days you got
to get up at eight and drive and you're
still gonna get there at six right Jesus
yep do you guys
ever have like an issue with like a guy
knocking on the door and you're like
having sex with his girlfriend or his
wife since like you guys hooked up with
people on the road I've never luckily
have avoided that like I mean you know
it's I've heard a horror story from this
one comic who said that that happened
like after he after he'd hook up with a
chick there was a knock in his door the
next day and uh a dude had a badge and
he walked in and said I'm a detective
from the local Department because this a
woman here claims you raped her last
night and the comic is like freaking the
[__] Isaac dude that never [__]
happened and so he sits a guy down and
he starts making him go into detail as
to what happened that night and it turns
out that that wasn't even a cop it was
that chick's crazy ex-boyfriend oh no
who just [__] was tailing her all
night and then just wanted he bought a
fake badge and wanted to hear like what
it is [__] crazy [__] like that
luckily I avoided all that like you know
I I got lucky man yeah I definitely you
know you'd hook up with chicks he'll
always be worried like [__] like one
time when I was in Little Rock I thought
you know what her boyfriend is here like
she took me back to her house and we
[__] in her in her dining room of all
places and the whole time like you know
what you think sometimes you can tell
when there's like other eyes you know
I'm like dude her husband is either into
this and watching it or something it was
so I got the [__] out of there as quick
as I could but like luckily I've never
had that you know happen where someone's
trying to kill me or you know kick my
ass over or anything like that like you
learn a lot like I'll tell you what
shocked me shocking thing that happened
to me was
I'm a cokehead I was a cold cat on the
road
so the coke took me wherever right you
know if a chick was involved I'm gone
you know so I'd be at the [__] club
and as a feature act I make believe I
was in the Payphone
and I'd be on the pay phone trying to
get blown yeah and I'll never forget
this one night this girl came up to me
because Wednesday night was Army night
yeah always it was Tuesday
Saturday and either Tuesday night or
Wednesday night was Army yeah and I'm
not kidding you it was the second night
of the week the second night of the week
was Army yeah like what at uh
at this particular Club is a popular
Club Wednesday night was Army night okay
because there was a base really there
was a base really close so I'll never
forget that I'm at the thing some girl
comes over very sweet looking girl I
mean that I have a chance to no we were
just talking are you from L.A and you've
really been in the movie we started
talking one thing led to another
she goes uh do you drink and yeah let me
buy you a drink and okay you know the
time I drank a little bit I was at least
sociable then like Caboose and I had a
drink and she goes I'm gonna go back in
with my girlfriends I'll come back thank
you for talking to me and then and she
came out and her girlfriends and then we
took they took me up to the corner yeah
and they'll pass on we talked and her
and she's like I gotta get out of here
with you and I bought like a gram of
blow I already had it in my pocket and
went back to the [__] thing and there
was a bottle of wine and a couple beers
in there from the week before sure and
we started drinking and I don't know
guys what I was thinking I don't know
what I was thinking so I was supposed to
think anything and I was in the bathroom
doing little bumps I didn't want them
back you know very clean cut [__] no you
know one of the times I went in the
bathroom I came out she was balls ass
naked
God knows what happened you know I don't
I don't of course in those days I didn't
bring I like to have condom s right so
sometimes you go down them they go down
and you finish and you go home whatever
that was it you can learn to have fun
then we realized she did blow right she
still have to like 5 30 in the morning I
slept all day the headline was kind of
pissed he's like I already got it I
don't know who the [__] headliner was
oh they always do that too when you get
laid in the headline it doesn't oh and
it doesn't man they get planned and we I
don't even think I [__] I just think
she was naked playing with herself or
whatever doing craziness out there
and you know that for like I didn't take
a name I didn't take a number she just
left and said I gotta go home I'm gonna
take a shower and go right to work
Thursday night I forgot all about it
yeah you know like Friday night she came
back and she goes Joey come here I want
you to meet my husband
I nearly [__] die oh [__] and I did
you know and I went back to the room and
I it teaches you about people yes I
learned a lot about that lessons about
people yeah man is there trust or
whatever I mean who walks in at 5 30 in
the morning whose husband says where the
[__] you been right no [__] you know
what the [__] were you they were happy
as [__] kissing this [__] I had a
situation
she didn't come back and talk to me
about it or not and she waved I met a
husband oh she was great yeah boom they
walked away and she just sat there yeah
we had a great time in the internet
whatever the [__] then there was another
time in Miami with a girl two weeks like
David in Miami driving her car it was
crazy and Sunday night always happens
Sunday night I look at her hand and
she's got a wedding band and I go what's
up we're talking and she goes I'm
getting married in three months so
there's no chitter chatter there's no
conversation and I go where is this guy
and she goes he's a weatherman on
television
so he has to be there at four in the
morning three in the morning so during
the week I don't see him and Austin hit
me I wouldn't see her Friday or Saturday
she would show back in the club Sunday
night like chip drop Magoo and this
Sunday night was I didn't see it because
I want to see you before you leave
Monday and she goes listen just take my
[__] number that's like take it out
I'm getting married and let me tell you
something that was
1998. yeah and last year when I went to
Miami I played a restaurant okay now has
Miami doesn't have an improv anymore
yeah Sports so home field sports
contacted the improving we do comedy
book them so they called me and they
want you to come down so I went down
there
Friday night when I'm walking on stage
she grabbed me after [__] wow 16
years
do you remember me and I go no and she
goes she took her glasses off
I go oh my God
but she was craziest girl and she dated
uh uh the singer from Van Halen oh David
Lee Roe this girl was a Savage she was
blonde beautiful bikini a husband or a
dad a dad owned an Audi dealership oh
wow like a Mercedes dealership or a
Porsche dealership so she lived in a
high-rise on the beach she had three
different cars in her [__] driveway
in her little parking garage what did
she expect when she talked to you now
yeah no I know I know what you did I'm
just saying was she like let's do it
again or nothing no I just came to see
the show yeah she came to see the show
and it was me yeah and she was saying
holy [__] did you ever ride dude I was
gonna one of the craziest nights I had
was in uh Oklahoma City at the looney
bin and I was featuring for this comic
you know just remain nameless but nice
enough guy but [__] man so one about the
trust thing there's this girl just
gorgeous she was like 6-1 beautiful
statues just stunning and she was at the
show and she walks up to Cascade because
oh she's a little bit drunk these guys
are so great blah blah and her husband
was with her husband was right there
with her and he goes he's about to go
hunting and it was one of the stupid
redneck ship they leave at like midnight
and they're not back and you know for
another two days or whatever right
because he's going hunting for the
weekend and it's just gonna be me and he
takes off to go hunting with his friends
from the club and she's there and
because y'all want to come back to my
place to [__] like husband just left
right and so and of course he had a
conversation [__] yeah we're going so I
had to drive and I'm driving me in the
headliner was actually just the
headliner myself and a bartender from
the from the club a woman oh man man
three guys redo she brings back to her
place and I'm sitting there dude I was
like [__] scared man I was one of my
first times on the road Joey I'm just
sitting there like I'm not gonna do
anything I'm just gonna sit here you
know and then sure enough we're hanging
out and she she had a pot leaf frame in
a picture and she also like had this
knife that she bought her husband that
had like some message on it like
engraved like I will love you forever it
was like this really pretty hunting
knife that the blade she got in good
that was sitting there and then she's
just talking she flashes us and then the
bartender just goes to [__] her like he
just takes her to her bedroom and starts
[__] her and as he's [__] her the
headliner grabs the the framed pot leaf
he steals a knife and then they have
like 300 bucks cash in a while he just
took that and he looks me and goes that
guy can't find his way home we're
getting the [__] out of here right now
and I'm like [__] so we just [__] she
left it was the craziest and I'm just
scared shitless the whole drive like
some [__] Something's Gonna [__]
happen like something's gonna [__]
happen did you see the chick the rest of
them never saw her again she never came
back that was the first night that was
on [__] Wednesday night there
whatever it was that was the first night
of the [__] run too so I was the
whole weekend I'm like any minute now
they're gonna come back and then we're
back at the condo and the headliner just
the whole weekend just had the knife
the middle of the night and I'd go
downstairs at first what the [__] is
that new just him you'd take the knife
out pitch black darkness throw it up
against the wall Again by the time we
left there was like 40 [__] Cuts in
the wall
it was crazy man I was like [__] I was
just right here oh man it was sometimes
on the road like I would go the craziest
things that happened to me weren't with
women it was drugs
see I was going into some dark [__]
place
Jesus
was there ever a moment you're like you
know what this isn't worth it was there
ever like were maybe right when it
started or right you're like ah you know
what this was not worth oh it's always
worth it
just that's the darkness for me that was
the real darkness for me some nights
going to cop it's funny I was telling me
my friend got shot in Florida
and uh he got blasted you know and and
they found him in a parking lot and
today I was talking to my friend and and
I'm like you know that's what happens
when you go together and she's like what
do you think he was doing oh he's
looking for Birds he was [__] buying
drugs you know they found them at four
in the afternoon he could have been
there God you know he left that morning
you know guys I remember one time and I
told this story last week because I was
in Perrysburg
and I said I always got bad luck in
burgs because I was in uh I was in
something West Virginia
and I heard these guys and I was like
that's when I was on a roll like I had
just done the Taco Bell commercial I had
just sent me sixty thousand dollars so
I'm just no I'm throwing away blood
and I go to [__] and I got a pocket full
of [__] cash I go to West Virginia
and nobody's got cocaine oh man
Wednesday has to wait staff oh yeah
Wednesday the wait stop is like nah
Thursday the wait staff is like nah
Friday they're like nah there's no Coke
I mean this is West Virginia
coal miners you can't say [__] on stage
like some of the one-nighters
the one night it was a ping pong table
that they put like a sheet over with
bricks underneath and you couldn't curse
it was a college it was [__] horrible
wait you had to stand on a ping pong
with little stairs on the side they
double reinforced it for fat people how
big were you 300 pounds [__] no I don't
[__] knowly they reinforced the
[__] thing oh my God cause I even
asked them I go that's not gonna hold me
like look underneath that's not gonna
work yeah they turned into like a brick
stage that's the place where they inside
a contract they wanted you to give them
25 so every time you said [__] wow and
like well I'm not going up call the
[__] yeah I'm saying happening and
that night I went into the bathroom I
heard the guys going and when they got
out I go what's up man they're like hey
man you're funny I'm like oh man it's
just something can you get me some more
can you sell me something like we're
done but we'll get you some come on
and me and Vinnie capola had a rental
cargo Vinnie give me a [__] call he's
like where are you going don't worry
buddy call me when you get back and I
[__] left him and I followed these
guys and took weeds and [__] bushes
and you know uh corn fields it was like
an hour of driving that's when we get
there and they go into a trailer
and they come out and they go how much
you want I go get like a gram 100 bucks
because 100 bucks I'll get you a pound I
knew something wasn't right I go pound
for 100 bucks and he came out he gave me
a [__] baggie and I go what is it
he's like a crank oh that's the best
[__]
speed this guy speed this guy's been up
for three months with one batch and I'm
like really that she'll kill you give me
get that [__] home I did a
couple bumps I was [__] up Jack did
you guys
ever get arrested on the road I did I've
never been luckily now what was that
like
I got arrested for [__] seven hours
in Idaho in uh Twin Falls or something
like that for what for shoplifting a
tent bringing it back in those days I
used to be a professional [__] tent I
used to be a professional and it came
out I saw this was before they all got
onto different computers you had two
free returns at Kmart before they put
you on file oh wow so if you went to
Kmart the first time with like something
for 90 dollars and said hi my brother
got me these floor mats
I already had them I bought them three
days earlier and you return the air
receipt not really they just scanned
they just scan it to see if they come
from that store you know I wouldn't walk
out of the store I'd just take them and
instead of walking out of the store just
walk up to the counter walk right up to
the counter I I just brought and in
those days didn't even think of looking
at film right right right I want to
Adept the film yet you know
so I would go up to the account and go I
need these they give me back cash okay
you go to that same store a week later
you make sure the same girl's not
working right the one I got these last
week okay and she'll give you a receipt
and they'll give you cash out of the
petty cash but
I think the third time they'll [__]
take your license in those days and
write your license information now
anytime after that you had a problem
right right right right so I was banging
this out everywhere anytime I needed
money on a triple run I just go into a
camera how you doing I just bought this
toaster for 200. okay fine here you know
215 plus tax didn't give you the tax
back that's [__] up when you're
stealing tax from [__] Kmart and I'm
banging these out in metropolitan cities
I'm going to Baltimore right in those
days I went I worked Denver I lived in
the Denver area and I would dress up in
the mornings This Is My Season the day
after Thanksgiving is when it starts and
it goes straight to Valentine's Day when
this time of the year was coming around
I was excited because that meant there
was no job before Uncle Joey I have one
job I have one job and I can break it
into one day just go out and Rob
and this is how I live from 94 to like
98 and I got busted doing it
in 96 or 97. yeah in in Twin Falls Idaho
wow I would just go anywhere I saw Kmart
Walmart anything like that
take some cappuccino machines would be
oh right right 95 I was banging out 300
a day one cappuccino machine every mall
I saw I banged out a cappuccino machine
some days I came home with 1500 geez oh
my God it was supposed to get caught
more just like a different world back
then dude it was crazy 20 years ago we
weren't really now no no I go okay let's
look at the camera they just go to a
camera and they'll see you walk them
with nothing you know what guys used to
do back when I said look at a Best Buy
way back in the days in the 90s it would
take uh
they would hollow out a speaker box
and just fill it with [__] and so a box
you would get like a big certain
whatever speaker right you know you know
as tall remember those tall big
cardboard but they would just fill it
with product and they would just pay 120
bucks for that one speaker they would
take the box up that we would get we get
you know swindled out all the time and
then you just leave and they [__] all
this product they wouldn't go return in
another store some crazy ship and it
would make you could make so much money
doing that it's amazing how smart people
are I worked at TVs and people would
take big like the big like Old Navy
shopping bags right and wrap it in tin
foil and then put another one but try to
make it look like just one bag sure and
the big thing they would steal is Crash
White Strips because they're so
expensive and they would just go we had
videos of people just going and running
out so that's why like when you go to
like a CVS and you see like the weird
stuff they have behind there it's
because the people steal it you know
what one time this uh when I worked at
Best Buy this was I wasn't even there
that day I was kind of bummed that I
missed it but so they had gotten these
new cam thousand dollar cam corner is
right I don't remember back best buys
used to have their back stock was
sometimes up in cages above the regular
aisles all right and so this kid was up
there he had just put all these
camcorders in and the scam was genius
like as he's up there on the ladder
right this woman is like Sarah can you
help me please being really annoying and
he's like yeah yeah and so he just
rushes down to help her and she takes
him over there and he leaves that cage
wide open dude like 30 of them were gone
like 30 this her husband went up got
them all and just walked right out like
it was [__] like that dude it was crazy
how people went you just can't do that
now I'd say how good I was Lady
I was thinking about contacting these
companies and telling them
are you [__] [__] like I'm making
a [__] living I'm making ten thousand
a month robbing you guys that's just me
right this way I can't imagine who else
is robbing yeah how many millions how
many millions you're getting robbed
that's how good I was with when I went
back to Boulder in 94 in 93 I robbed
like beside the sports betting job I had
and I'm ashamed to say this
I that's all I did yeah I got to the
point where I would just go in front of
Kmart with my bicycle and hang out a
grown man
and I look for people coming out
dropping receipts oh yeah that happens
all the time I might pick up a receipt
forty dollars I'm in that's good I go I
got weed and I got lunch now I need
another receipt that's the way to do it
that's how I did it I just wait there
because nobody nobody keeps a receipt
everybody tosses people dropping
receipts one time somebody dropped a
[__] lawn mower receipt for four
minutes no way I took the receipt and I
took it all the way to Longmont Colorado
and went to that Kmart
and I took a lawnmower brought it up got
the four bills back kept the receipt I
just had it just in case and I went back
to bo uh to Boulder back the [__]
damn more I made 800 for the [__]
damn plus tax
I would hit the Westminster Mall
Baltimore Longmont mall I would go all
the way to Cheyenne Wyoming and I was
right where I went down this is how
[__] crafty I was so I wouldn't go
back to places no evidence I would just
put
uh 10 15. they could be doing anything
Aurora that's it yeah you didn't know
what it said
not even quick meetings that's law order
101. no no you're meeting a friend
Boulder Mall yeah at 3 20. that's
[__] but if I just put more they
don't know if you could say you had a
job there yeah whatever like I was there
so I would know where I would be the
week before so I wouldn't go back and I
would never go back I had like a little
count and I just put like bees on it I
had no Westminster sure uh Aurora
[__] I hit ever Arvada I hit every
mall that had a [__] came on all the
way in the state of Colorado that I
would just start all over here from
Wyoming all the way to [__] that do you
have like a company list or how did he
find him well he just drove around I
just drove around so I saw them all off
the one off the 70 or the I-25 you just
got lost in [__] everywhere yeah John
Elway Ville oh yeah [__] all those bills
in Denver I used to run
so wait when you got arrested when
you're on your gig did you make the next
gig I made the gig that's awesome they
gave they let me out on my own
reconnaissance I told him to suck my
dick there's still a warrant in Twin
Falls I miss the main one how long does
that last who the [__] that's crazy yeah
[__] you're never gonna go back
my fishing days are over you know what
I'm saying I got a warrant someday
um I don't know people very upset right
now I ain't [__] going there exactly
these people that want to go back and
I'll sneak and [__] you yeah there's no
reason for me to [__] this is everything
yeah it's funny because uh I'm trying to
get I'm trying to get a passport but I
want to know or I'm not going to spend
unnecessary money yeah so the passport's
the first thing if these people [__]
it's all in the paperwork soil these
people approve me [__] Seattle and [__]
that one I'll just go to Cuba yeah if
cat if I could find a way to definitely
enter Canada like I got an attorney
right now that's answering questions and
you have to fill out a form and right
the exact gig we're gonna probably go to
Calgary if I could go there with that
warrant not now if Canada goes you could
come in but you gotta take that one in
Seattle and take care of the warning in
Seattle right the only travel I want to
do right now is a passport to go to Cuba
and maybe go to London to see my Irish
buddies over there maybe to Australia
but Canada is too strict they're not
going to let me in they're gonna break
my [__] balls what are you giggling
with Buddy
I'm just imagining like
Calgary exploding right now
well there's a comedy club up there that
I work in Minneapolis because of they
have that how was that one how was that
one in Minneapolis the house I love it
because I'm doing the one in Phoenix in
a couple of weeks yeah I love it he's a
great guy yeah I met him in Montreal I
love America man you walk around yeah
I'll probably [__] you know I'll do a
couple things I'm only there Thursday
through Sunday it's so weird you stay in
town
the only Advantage I have of staying in
town is that I get to see my family sure
the whole week I get to hang out with
Lee a little bit
but besides that I gotta tell you
I'm just becoming a professional workout
yeah that's all I do is I'm a
professional worker either I do the
Kettlebell work I feel Italy that would
have made you [__] drool what do you
do I did everything I did five sets of
squats five sets of Queens five sets of
one arm curls and then five sets of two
arm swings do you see the video he put
up today no he put up a video of this
guy
doing one arm Swings with a 106 pounds
who's this the guy who teaches us oh
nice we go Tuesday morning
how's your back that's way better so
you're all Jim what's going on with the
ex-girlfriend you see any more of the
blonde she's still at the bookstore she
took your job dude she [__] took the
job she took my dog she took my cat and
uh now she [__] off and went to Ohio
well she went back it shouldn't even
have the pets anymore that's [__]
that's that that's What Hurts the Most
is I miss my dog I miss my cat she gave
the cat and the dog away yeah yeah you
believe not she gave the dog to her
[__] dad who lives up in Cleveland
she went to Cincinnati and then I think
the cat is here with her old friend it's
like man [__] that [__] crazy go back
to Cincinnati before she didn't have a
bad year yeah I know she was a young
girl yeah that's what happened that's
what happened you over this hiding the
[__] stealing the [__] cradle hanging
[__] young chicks and [__] hey man
that's what you get right good so I
can't believe you have been watching
that's your [__] they were talking
that's your show I was watching
something the other day and they talked
a lot about Laredo narcos there was
something else I was watching
uh drugs Inc and they were talking about
how drugs come up and the big Port now
is Laredo oh yeah
everybody's [__] up in Laredo they
don't know what's what the [__] gangs
dude Laredo is that it's always been
that way like there was you know my mom
told me a story there was a dude there
who was like the mayor for like 40 years
40. yeah like like that was this guy
that that isn't possible but yeah the
[__] like that always happened he's like
this because that guy was a mayor when I
was [__] when my mom was a kid that
guy was a [__] mayor you know like
this that's how [__] happens down there
like this it's so [__] crazy man like
it's yeah it's oh God it was when I uh
you know my my my uncle uh you know he's
not rich he he just had his own business
you know worked hard had his own
business he never had he wasn't like
rolling in cash but just because he
owned his own business one day I was
babysitting his two sons my little
cousins right we're just sitting there
playing football in the yard all that
stupid [__] video games and I get a
phone call goes hey are you with the
boys right now and I go yeah yeah why he
goes just go inside if you don't mind I
was like yeah what's up turns out that
he just got a call saying hey we know
where your kids are we're gonna go get
them unless you give us 10 grand like we
get phone calls like that all the time
and none of them was it was all just
people desperate trying to but enough of
that kidnapping [__] happens that the
people fall for it I'm like okay you
know like it's yeah it's dude laredo's
[__] crazy place I mean I'd love it
it's you know it's it's home but man oh
you get some good [__] drugs oh man
well I used to go to El Paso oh my God I
used to be bouncing the [__] whole
five days I was there there was some
coke all you had to do was look at it
[__] up
what's up Lisa we're coming from that
Acid Trip Monday night bro
we had a 250 I thought about this what'd
you think about Lee I had a 250
milligrams
I know still smoke The Joint the dab
and then took one of the strongest hits
of acid
I can imagine it was crazy
[Laughter]
listen sometimes you do a drug an edible
like that was an edible we did a couple
weeks ago but I went home I said okay
I'm hungry right I'm not gonna overdo it
right let me just eat an apple and my
wife gets a bunch of fruit right and at
night I'll Attack that first
and the [__] fruit like sometimes you
go home and there's like egg salad sure
and I'll get like two four four saltine
crackers and I'll eat a little bit of
eggs out with four crackers and I'm good
for them I drink a little coffee I watch
TV this one that I ate every once I ate
that banana and that Apple like it's set
it happened tonight and people will not
even you can't eat if you eat you fail
you fail and then especially if you do
Edibles on a day of like kettlebells
anything when you're moving metal right
like Monday Lee and I went to jiu jitsu
and I totally on the way I'm Gonna Leave
feel your legs they're sweating
we worked out today it's 100 degrees you
know you're hungry that's one hungry but
that's it I did like today I did a good
Kettlebell workout I know tonight
you're gonna be feeling about 11 years
oh my God your Apple you got to go to
bed you gotta drink coffee and go to bed
like a cup of decaf really get you and
go to bed because anything after like by
11 20 I I'm looking at my fingers
like maybe I should just bite one of my
[__] like you get so high like one
cent okay I ate all the fruit I eat all
the almonds you know because I got 100
calorie bags of almonds once I eat three
of those then that's it if I eat three
bags of almonds and I'm still [__]
hungry
I start on the leftovers once I kill the
leftovers you know I sometimes the three
different leftovers yeah there's not
enough for a meal but if you eat the
three leftovers together it's okay it's
a meal yeah I love those plates but I
did one of those like had to be two
weeks ago an edible kettlebell day
[__] I went home I ate the fruit the
[__] uh the three leftovers then I
started eyeballing the salamis the ham
and cheese my wife gets ham and cheese I
told her stop but the [__] thin
sliced ham and cheese we had no bread at
the house okay I haven't had white bread
in [__] months the white bread is the
devil dude it's evil bro listen when I'm
stoned again I'll just take a tub out of
butter yeah and I can sit there with a
knife and make white bread with butter
and I don't have 10 of them now that
what's sad is that white bread is so bad
for you but white bread and butter is
the best [__] snack on the [__]
planet oh my God it is just amazing late
night how much heat yeah when I went
home on that acid
I always [__] I got I went home well I
got high of the weed first I called him
and he we got really high outside right
by the time I went upstairs my wife was
awake and the baby was oh then that
weren't out that she was in the room I
could hear her and then no I'm not you
know telling that story real quick
because it was funny what the no why not
no I'm not oh she's a [__] truck
those are two favorite words no I'm not
no problem
thank you no problem
I'm gonna make hamburgers and fries I'm
Gonna Bake these uh healthy french fries
I said then the oven the house is going
to be 2 000 degrees we're about to hit a
week uh heat storm here this week it's
gonna be 100 tomorrow 105 I said yeah
it'll be [__] hot the next two days
we're sweating tomorrow morning Doug oh
yeah oh damn it it's gonna get cold
again they said it's gonna say next week
next week that's it it's me like the
hottest month in California is September
yes that's what people do not realize
this month it's not all this week
everywhere else but like tomorrow and
then yeah that'll be it hopefully yeah
listen I don't give a [__] yeah you know
we're so spoiled out here it doesn't
really [__] a couple of more weeks of
this [__] is fine you know yeah but the
other night I really Lee said
I had a big problem when I was a kid
like
I like to Triple when I heard Ozzy
Osbourne on Fairies Wear Boots smoking
and tripping is all that you do I lost
my [__] right you know what people
don't realize is okay
let's say
uh
uh unless this [__] LeBron yeah
LeBron takes a picture
tonight just us [__] around LeBron
takes a picture of himself with a
certain type of water and he instagramed
and he has a million followers right ten
percent of people gonna buy that water
no question just makes sense
you gotta understand when I was a kid
when I heard the beat I didn't like the
[__] beetles but when I heard that
they went to India and the acid and came
back and then music changed okay that
was one thing
that was okay that was one testimonial
then I heard then I heard Hendrix used
to put it on his band and it would sweat
through his [__] yeah into his
eyeballs I don't [__] know I'm not
gonna quote I've heard that too though
but I know he ate a lot of acid okay and
I listened to his music and I was like
God damn then there were like three
other people who I know that talked
about acid so acid always had a high
testimonial with me I knew eventually
once I loved refill like how much I
really liked razor there's a scene I'd
call Lee right away the reason why I
like this narcos so much yeah is because
I think the guys are great actor you
know what Pablo Escobar looks like it's
like this black kid that played James
Brown he did a great job as James Brown
yeah yeah but this guy has something oh
he's Escobar that's what he's playing no
no okay the guy that's playing Escobar
and narcos is a Brazilian guy nobody
knocks him for Spanish
everybody who's Spanish it's like when I
went to see Scarface I was a little
insulted at first doesn't matter it's Al
Pacino who gives a [__] right right I
don't care if he [__] up the words it's
a movie this guy it's not that he's
created this uh
he's such a great actor like I told Lee
if this guy was English or Australian
everybody would know about him because
oh my God he's so good but he's a [__]
cover of every magazine right he's a
happiest so [__] him he's not that good
looking he's skinny but he plays Fat
yeah sometimes he goes like this with
his stomach and he puts his sneakers on
and he walks around and he plays Fat but
the beginning of episode Wagner Wagner
Mora the the beginning of the beginning
of episode eight and nine he's at the
jail it's it's called La Cathedral okay
yeah and it opens up with him
looking at a truck getting unloaded
and you see it going into the port and
like what is it and the guys like it
cheats Plumbing materials it's uniforms
for the guards okay guy passes it
through he pulls him to the jail they
open up the back it's [__] filled
with chicks bags of blow [__] fish
tanks filled with lobsters you know a
gambling casino people the guards again
on the Cameron casinos and people are
yelling and screaming the women are
going into the casino they're playing
cards he's upstairs he's he's ahead of
the [__] game he's looking at the
mountains
he's looking at what's going on he's
hearing what's going on
and all of a sudden you see this thing
in the picture that's going like this
it's a pot plant
[Laughter]
the wind's blowing he looks at the
pipeline so here in a [__] jail like
you just unloaded okay yes Casino
material chicks they just unloaded a
party in anybody's World in a prison
you're supposed to be in jail right but
to top it off you're growing weed the
best weed in the world he looks at the
plant he walks over to it
you see him scrape through the [__]
leaves there's a butt hanging there Thug
he gets the bud and he goes
and he closes his eyes and then while
I'm looking at him like only I would do
something like that like he's in heaven
he's sniffing that bud they're all
downstairs with broads and whatever he
sniffs it he looks at it he Clips it and
he puts in his top pocket and he walks
down and that's the whole scene it's a
six minute scene to him just inhaling
the weed you know oh that's great that's
a testimonial like this guy right I
loved that hole so the first time I did
acid I was like I don't remember when or
with who I don't remember I know I liked
it because it took my mind somewhere
else sure and I was telling Lee that
night when I got up the next point I hit
Lee with 22 [__] ideas
acid is basically putting you in a room
with no let me tell you something guys
you really want to write really good
comedy
wake up get a cup of coffee or whatever
you do in the morning don't turn nothing
on right don't get stimulated by
anything no stimulation
sit there for two hours with a pen and a
piece of paper have your coffee let the
coffee stimulate you a little bit if you
want to smoke a half a joint maybe take
two Puffs of a cigarette whatever you do
no stimulation from television magazines
no thoughts shoved into your mind no
commercials nothing sit there for an
hour and watch where your mind will go
do that for eight hours which is unheard
of but when you're in prison that's what
happens that's where the Urgent solitude
because your mind goes somewhere else
you get to a different level with your
mind on your own terms
when you do acid if it's really good
acid
it's [__] it'll break you down you know
and Lee was like how many times did you
do that growing up and go after my
mother died I was so confused sure it
didn't really matter what I felt like
the acid would make me normal right the
acid I would go home and put on sabotage
and that would give me the answer to all
my problems if I listen to sabotaged or
Hole in the Sky that's I I would be fine
after I go to sleep like a [__]
Champion the next day I'd be energetic
all my mind was on cylinders that's what
acid is for me and it always has been
over the years I I haven't been that
high like that way in 15 years no 90 85
was the real last time I really really
really got [__] baked on acid like
Jesus I was seeing things in lights the
other night I didn't get to that level
but with another hit oh
I would have gone right over the [__]
ah does the acid have a little bit of
not speed but like yeah right poison oh
my God what rat poison that's what gets
you all [__] happy Yeah because it
like it was crazy man I I texted you in
five uh at five in the morning oh no I
was done already and you wouldn't have
been able to eat because once you go to
get the breakfast the acid kicks back up
because we will smoke The Joint should I
keep the acid coming back with joints
that's why I said to you Sunday night
we're all 15 [__] joints well you
didn't give me any I gave you one that
we smoked one that night
five in the morning I started I
organized my [__] bathroom
it was crazy it was like the letters
were moving on my phone it was
so he wouldn't [__] answer the phone
I finally went to bed I think at 1 15.
that was so [__] high and I was
laying on this side and I could feel my
heart beating on because once you start
thinking about it so once I flipped over
I didn't want my heart my wife to feel
my heart beating but once I flipped over
I was fine I went right to bed I got up
a couple times like I woke up thinking I
can't believe I fell asleep I had those
acid dreams and [__] like that
crazy okay I tried to jack off to like
go to bed and it could it wouldn't work
no you can't whack off on that's no sex
on that [__] oh Jesus the sex is good if
you were the freak that's kind of asking
and she's working your horn and she's
putting fingers up your ass right I took
a lot of shits do you [__] a lot no that
was the speed maybe it was the Subway
because that yeah well the subway too
who would go to the subway on acid only
this [__] joke I was high from the
edible and I hadn't I didn't have dinner
so I was I just went and got a turkeys
up a turkey [__] sub that's that's
what made you [__] don't blame it on the
acid the chicken but it lift that ass
yeah when you went to eat I was like
that's it he's gonna go to bed and then
I drank call I did something you know so
now I was off and running I'm like oh my
God
I am [__] blasted this cannot be and
I did a periscope I was giggling I went
outside and I smoked I smoked and when I
almost fell on the stairs I tell you
that on the acid no I was an instrument
falling down the [__] my front stairs
I went to pop up and I'm like oh [__]
it almost fell I fell over the
Kettlebell my wife left South outside I
had really like dark thoughts it was
weird what kind of dark thoughts again
like I was like I felt bad for a minute
like for dating Paula like I was like
she could have like a lawyer boyfriend
or something like that and not have to
deal with like a create like this
craziness and like the crazy people on
Twitter
and like weird stuff like that and then
I was like thinking about just me doing
acid
it's it's weird for me man like you did
all this stuff as a kid I didn't did you
ever dream of doing acid this was told
from like fifth grade they dare did you
put music on that night no no no next
time we'll bring a music in there yeah
yeah we're gonna darken it get some
candles Sunday night we're doing an acid
[__] podcast oh nice
we got like the Edibles on watching the
podcast that's great we got [__] some
Reef We're Gonna Roll a few joints and
then uh someone's gonna fall down those
stairs we're gonna have to bring like
analyzer in here or something not
smoking here let me give some shout outs
real quick here my man Harry who came to
the storytelling shows that happening he
got hit he got there late he knows I
love him Mike roulette Ryan Murphy Rob
Lawler Sergeant Cassidy over there
[__] holding it down
Ricky neb2 will Fred o disler Amy my my
buddy one by one podcast and Nolan E3 a
couple shout outs for you [__]
Savages and [__] out there and podcast
bill
look at your little star I love it uh
you guys like music and we're talking
about the beat like
it's 2015. the Beatles broke up in 71 or
something like that not even yeah you
know
when I was growing up everybody wouldn't
shut the [__] up about the boys
you know it wouldn't it wouldn't shut
the [__] up they would not shut the [__]
up the Beatles are getting back together
blah blah blah meanwhile [__] Paul
McCartney's writing some monsters he
wrote monsters in the 70s and John
Lennon's firing at him and George
Harrison wrote 33 in the third Ringo
Starr's just Ringo Starr he's he's
somewhere jumping up right I'm trying to
put an all-star band together with a
bunch of [__] addicts and [__] and
they gotta cancel the Tour 12 dates in
nobody's showing up no more Ringo we
thought it was a joke though we don't
want to play with you you're a [__]
joke but it was it was really weird how
people had hope and somebody had put the
kids I hung out with hated two people in
Jersey in high school I hung out with
these guys and they hated two bands The
Beatles to hang out with these guys you
had to hate two bands the pills and
Bruce Springsteen like Bruce Springsteen
came out of the party you had to leave
or break the [__] record player like
that's it like you gotta [__] do
something for the record you couldn't be
around the music no we want
[Laughter]
it was on today live it was on today
live and it was pretty impressive how he
did it he introduced the band before he
did it pretty [__] cool but I'll
never forget that John Lennon got shot
on a Monday night Monday night football
coach Tuesday night I'm walking into
school in that portrait of The Beatles
right somebody I already put an x on job
that's how much they hated the Beatles
the dudes I lived with we walked by and
they're like look at that they're really
put an x on his head we were [__]
dying one down three together one down
three to [__] go it's not that I
hated the Beatles it's that the kids
that wore the Beatles you got sick of
them yeah I got sick of those
[__] it was until
1983 so I went to Aspen
that there was a bunch of beetle albums
the guys that in the daytime if you're
here you could play music I was there by
myself and you know elevation smoking
weed we gotta put music on to settle you
and that with the Rubber Sole I started
getting into those and the best right
Sergeant Pepper's and uh
and that's when I learned about the
Beatles sitting there by myself I really
learned a lot about the without nobody
forcing them down my throat I broke down
the music by myself and said this is
[__] brilliant then I listened to all
the Paul McCartney stuff John Lennon
stuff and you know woman is the [__]
of the world I mean he's got some
[__] crazy [__] y'all wanted and I
didn't get into it as much as I thought
you know but it was very interesting
like there's bands to me that people say
oh my God then you bring it home and
this is garbage it's just some guy you
know the Beatles was something for me
that it was an education later on I'm
happy I didn't get into the Beatles when
I was 16. I'm happy to get into them and
I was in my 20s and then again like in
80 before I got locked up I got into a
uh I hated those early [__] love me dude
no no none of that [__] Works in my
world I like the craziness I like let
that let it be he starts with revolver
and rubber Souls
it's just brilliant yeah man and I
didn't know at that time you know it's
it's it's really weird if you're young
you listen to the podcast you like a
certain type of music and right now
you're saying that that other music
sucks 10 years from now you're not gonna
feel like that yeah you're gonna your
your music catalog is gonna expand and
people are going to giggle at you and
ship you don't give a [__] then it's
gonna expand again then it's gonna
expand again I remember going from heavy
metal to Sade
and going what the [__] is going like I
bought the first two shot Days those are
good brilliant
man uh just just amazing music and
people go I can't believe you have shot
down listen to the first two albums dawg
Sade will knock you [__] stops off
you know I remember buying Rick James I
ended up buying all different type of
[__] music my dad he would listen to
if he had me listen to everything The
Beatles one day the who the next
Metallica he was one he's the one who
called me up and told me about grunge
when I was a kid because you got to hear
this [__] man like he [__] like he
all all that [__] he would listen from
you know the Beatles to like that
[__] acid jazz type mahavishnu
Progressive Jazz [__] like all that
stuff dude you just listen to everything
and you yeah you you can if you really
love music you can appreciate what's
great about every facet of it like any
type of genre anything it's like oh man
and the Beatles at one point you were
talking about their solo [__] I'm still
not convinced that they weren't still
writing with each other you even though
they've broken up and we're talking all
this [__] because their solo [__] is
still so [__] good you know what I
mean but I'm like if if it finds out 10
years from now uh by the way yeah we
never we were all writing each other's
[__] too back to like I would believe it
because if you guys like music
and we all do we really we really enjoy
music that's like you and I bonded with
Chinese food and music we really like
music
I wish that I was I had a very special
music-wise like I was very fortunate
there always people always talk about
time machines oh man it's [__] Momo
he was just looking at me like [__]
crosstalk uh people always talk to me
about me
there isn't he I'm an old man I'm out of
touch and I gotta tell you something man
if I could do it all over again if I
could go to a time machine I'd want to
get dropped in 1971. I was about to say
71 or 72. except no it was straight till
1980 straight to when uh John Bonham
died oh yeah right there that was the
end of it all right there right and then
Ozzy Osbourne came in all that stuff
with the heavy metal but I'm talking
about when when Paul McCartney was
dueling Elton John when Elton John ran
this country and we've had this
discussion not with you on the podcast
before you know I think I was on Joe's
one time we're talking about when Elton
John ran this country which was 72 to
77. yeah
and then he was running things but then
Paul McCartney would show up with Band
on the Run and [__] all Loves Me Do
songs and all this [__] then John Lennon
showed up with imagining and when I when
I was still not talking about what Led
Zeppelin UFO and and the stones were
doing and the Shanker brothers and and
the [__] you know Pink Floyd was
doing in 75 we're not even talking about
all this what you know I watched that
show the 70s on CNN right they did
specials with Tom Hanks produced them in
1973 this country spent two billion
dollars on concert tickets and if you
look at just tonight go home and Google
who was on tour in 1973 everybody
everybody the heart everybody heart was
on tour you know everybody he was on
[__] door I mean that was the big
thing you went to see everybody and
nobody got all [__] door right yes
you know all these bands The Who
everybody toured every two or three
years the stones came what 71 73 75 I'm
don't quote me on that but it was such a
different [__] time and no matter you
know some people like the Elvis Sarah
some people say that Elvis era I don't
like the early Stones uh the early
Beatles or even the early Stones as much
yeah there's a part where the stones
where they pick up and they just blow my
[__] doors off yeah man yeah I you
know what you know what my favorite
Stones is some girls which is a lot of
people don't like it but I [__] love
it
miss you oh come on I'm a freshman year
dog that [__] took me some girls is the
[__] that
um was taking [__] apart if you
watch the beginning of that close range
after Sean Penn has the beef
they [__] do that song and you'll and
it takes you right when
you know when you do the soundtrack to
your life you think of those Summers you
think of every summer like the biggest
summer for me was you know uh Peter
Frampton Comes Alive yeah Jesus Christ
that was the summer of 76. no matter
where you went I still remember the
summer when it was Hey Hey My My
um
rock and roll will never die that is
this is your this is your biography
these are things that the footnotes is
what you remember whenever you're
watching a movie and they go back and
they flash back what's the first one
they drop on you the music the music the
music to bring you right back there boom
boom boom boom boom boom boom boom boom
boom boom boom boom
[Music]
that's still a [__] that's still the
thing 16 year old Steve Winwood he was
16 singing that [__] song that's
what's crazy he's sixth imagine being 16
years old and singing the way he sang in
that [__] song that is crazy
Steve would oh was it um yeah Spencer
Davis Group give me some loving give me
some love [__] man he's [__] 16 years
old they said they sound like a Ray
Charles I read something once and they
were like he drove people crazy that jam
and I was a little boy
see what year that came out Spencer
Davis I'm gonna say like what 67
and I'm so well this Wikipedia this is
2013 but that's not real
[Laughter]
[Music]
[__] opening man forget it
I want to give a shout out to
Michael and Marcy Johnson sent me a
little package from my daughter some
bows they're up there in the Bay Area
serving all the California Sierra Realty
925-628 Mike Michael and Marcy Johnson
thank you for the present from my
daughter it's beautiful
Italy
[Music]
this is the best part
with that organ
I was a little kid I thought I was a
surfer
Killingly there used to be a bottles and
James commercial
with this with this in
1988 1987. [__] yeah man it was [__]
tremendous they showed like a a big
Hawaiian
cutting a pineapple and as soon as he
cuts a pineapple and it falls
19 something some Hawaiians thought how
cool would it be if they added fruit to
wine and the fruit cooler and [__]
that song Still is the jam of all jams
it's freaking amazing how long have you
been doing comedy
probably
1995 of some winner of 1995 it was 20
years 20 years now congratulations thank
you thank you for sure I wanted to call
you and I said you know what thanks man
he's trying to promote it and uh I
appreciate it it means a lot to it means
the world oh my God I know how hard
you've worked I know
varying for a hard time you were getting
stroked in this business you can sign
you talk to you know they disappeared
they're [__] mind [__] you got
some people to believe in you and you
know thank God for Gabriel oh man
Gabriel is the he's such a saint there
and he's just listen man successful
people like that no they have to pass
the bucket right and uh Gabriel has a
great attitude for work and uh
I'm happy you got together you can't
really helped Steve Simone here oh yeah
man he put you know he fought for me for
the Comedy Central spot you know these
are the type of guys that'll work
forever because
they're great people just great people
and I mean I I gotta hand it to you
because you've worked hard you've been
through the ups and downs man you've
been fighting for [__] years
back crazy girlfriends you know the
Jersey photographers
and then she didn't want to leave you
alone and you got this little blonde
that was 20 with long legs you shoved
the tongue up her ass and she couldn't
take it no more she's going back to Ohio
say I can't take this number
putting tongues in my ass
[Laughter]
oh
Joe's more dirty freak dog you know
whatever happens he's got he plows to
these Freaks and about a year you'll see
Jerry no more bracelets she took
everything the bracelet
the little Christian chain and he's back
on Laurel Canyon solo this little
[__] studio apartment over there how
many [__] have gone you don't even
have Windows over there you just kill
them and throw them out
how long have you been with this about a
year about a year yeah I love that's it
oh she's great yeah I'm gonna do for a
living nothing yet she's just moved out
here so she's gonna figure that out all
right Florida Florida yeah yeah she got
drug problems
she loves smoking weed I'll tell you oh
bro we don't you know only this [__]
gym up you want to smoke some more hash
no not really it's just a little weed I
got
put a little hashish before you go home
I don't want to send you a home all
straight and [__] I'm not straight bro
[Laughter]
what I want out on the internet yeah
what it's not like what I want on the
internet
[Laughter]
look at the shape of you uh it's and you
only ate 100 milligrams
nice
700 I'm sure 700. at least three or four
you wait a hundred yeah right you eat
100 milligrams oh 250s that's it you
weighed 150 milligrams sure
that's not enough
[__] all right
and I'm very proud of you Jerry thank
you so much happy on tonight because I
really appreciate that man thank you
people think uh
there's no timeline on Art no no no
there's no timeline and as long as you
go if you get into calming you're going
after six years if I don't make it I'm
quitting [__] Joey Diaz listen man six
years is when you start to understand
the game a little bit as much as you
think you're [__] miltonborough you
don't know dick you don't know dick at
six years and at 10 years you don't
really know dick again you think like I
got this you don't really know dick you
know you start really putting it
together at 16 right and then you really
start getting good I mean Burr's been
around for [__] years nobody knew
that Sebastian's been around for 15
[__] years Ralphie's been around for
25 [__] years you know Dane Cook's
been around for 20 [__] years you
know you just think these people came
out of out of nowhere never out of
nowhere it's never like that so but
again you know whether you're a guitar
player a [__] drummer you want to be
a sound tech a producer these are all
the ingredients that go into this it's
time patience you gotta live in a studio
apartment you gotta run through [__]
women and throw them off
sometimes they take your cat you know
sometimes they take your dog I went
through that [__] they took my dog twice
[__] women [__] Savage evil oh you
gave me the best advice ever though what
happened I'll never forget this we're
talking about that like how you know hey
you basically said there's no timetables
years ago we were talking about this and
you said as long as you're still going
up at night and doing comedy in La
you're in the fight you're in it you're
you're swinging that's all that matters
you want to be up there swinging and
that's that's all that matters like if
you can continue to do that and that's I
think the difference is a lot of people
when they don't have that all it didn't
happen for me in six years they leave or
they quit or they walk away and it's
like well you know what the miracle you
didn't let the miracle happen right you
didn't believe in the miracle you didn't
believe in yourself which is the [__]
biggest thing before the work before
quitting your job before telling your
mom to suck your dick you're moving out
of the basement before all these things
what makes you do all these things with
confidence yeah is the belief it's when
I go to my best friend Lee and I quit my
job today right and Lee's like how'd you
[__] do it man aren't you worried and
you look at lean you're gonna know it's
all going to work out you know following
a friend of mine he's paying five
thousand a month for rent yo
where it doesn't matter and I go how are
you making that nut he goes believe it
or not
the first month I had a hard time
and a guy called me from 10 years ago
for a writing job we got we picked up a
year Boom book and it's it's going to
cover the [__] red and the spread and
everything for a year and a half or I'll
find something else yeah sometimes you
got to put yourself in that position
you know if something happens you need
three thousand a month all sudden you
start making three times you figure out
how to do all of a sudden you put six
grand up also you start figuring out how
to make [__] six grand it's very uh
it's true I don't know how to even
describe it it's a certain belief that
you have to uh have in yourself to get
into any of this [__] whether you go to
vocational school to become a plumber
nobody's a plumber overnight no it comes
from an electrician a mechanics mechanic
overnight look at the shape of this
[__] well how exciting is it like
when you start like noticing making
you're making money like
I don't even think it's for me when
because I still don't make you know I'm
not like rolling in dough or anything
like that but you know what it is what's
exciting is when you know you're getting
better like that's what's awesome is
when you all of a sudden when you start
finishing shows you're like holy [__]
like [__] man that was that was like way
better for me it happened about seven
years in I don't know if you remember
that feeling that you get after when all
of a sudden you know you would always do
okay that's why you kept doing it but
then one night you just destroy and like
everything works right and those are
rare sets but when you don't talk about
those nights it doesn't matter what and
also you're like oh wow I just did that
like [__] that's the best feeling that's
better than any paycheck you're gonna
get but is this that moment when you
start realizing I'm actually good at
like I'm actually getting good at this I
actually know how to do this like I'm
actually that's the [__] Untouchable
feeling one of my biggest highlights I
started in 91.
and from 91 to 93 I was uh I was that
guy that always had a card I'm a
Canadian but I would cancel every game
when I was in New York I'd stop in
Harlem and get a bag of coke and do a
line and not show up at the gig I really
wasn't but when I realized the work that
had to go into it
said okay now it's time to roll up my
sleeves right for me to do this
professionally yeah and to make a living
I gotta tell you what my first highlight
was and it had nothing to do with money
so this was I was going through hell I'm
going through hell my ex-wife I'm living
on the [__] floor right you know my
job sucks I I'm not making Child Support
I'm you know my child support 700 I'm
coming up with 550. you know it's just a
horrible time in my [__] life and
I'll never forget going Jimmy beta
called me up on then he goes hey man I
got this bar pays 50 bucks why don't you
come do 15 minutes and I'm like sweating
like 15 minutes
like that was [__] but I had
something you know sure I could
improvise
like that's the best that's the hardest
thing to do and if you can do that oh
man when I first started comedy I
refused to write material right like
crowd work crowd work and improvise yeah
and talk [__] and I never forget we went
to some bar one night you know and it
was any like for me now I would go in
there and go Jesus Christ but then you
know you're a superstar I'm going to
Pocatello [__] hey man where you
going next week I'm going to New York
where are you going Pocatello [__] [__]
well I think that's maybe more what I
meant not necessarily money but like
when you started booking more and more
gigs no no but here's the moment that
killed me we were at this bar on a
Wednesday night
Jimmy better go up there and do 20
minutes
and I went up there and you know usually
I would be on a [__] stopwatch right
three minutes you know another day right
done you know it's like when I go to jiu
jitsu the first two years I would try to
avoid sparring okay I gotta go yeah yeah
technique and [__] and uh
one night I I did really well
and they finally gave me the light and
when I got all four Comics were waiting
waiting young guys right and they were
high-fiving me that was [__] great
and Jimmy Betty comes on and goes bro
you did 38 minutes they're the best
no I didn't he goes yes you did it
because I was outside getting high I
forgot to give you the light wow
and I'll never forget getting in my car
and that to me was the highest moment
absolutely [__] career
when you do when you do a set like he
said let's say you're supposed to do 20
and he took 25 30 so 38 right and you
destroy and then you get off stage and
you didn't even get to tell like five
jokes that you're hoping you know what I
mean that's the best feeling I remember
going home and I'll tell you what
exactly what I did in those days there
was a common newspaper and in the back
of it it had all the
it had all the top uh clubs in the
country okay at every Club in the
country just the last but there was also
a Judy Carter book that I had sure and
it had uh you know all the agencies in
LA and I remember that night I went home
and circled agencies like I was ready
you know I'm calling these people to see
who's performing arts you're getting a
call from me tomorrow I did 38 minutes
at Ringo's eight ball in last night over
in Falcon Colorado like I thought I was
this [__] but that mountain
like the money for me
never really matters I knew when I got
in there I eliminated the money from my
mind I did that going in because I
didn't want to have no inclinations that
I was going to make absolutely the first
time I read real money doing comedy was
nine years and eight years and I booked
the Taco Bell commercial and I must have
made a small [__] Fortune 100 Grand
in eight months I made 80 something 60
Grand like from August no I made 80
grand from August to December nice with
a Taco Bell commercial beginning because
they didn't know the dog was going to
get hot so they planted during the World
Series a spots a spots a spots I'm in
Clark
spots because a spots where people don't
know when you get like a rotation like
you have cable Cable pay like three
thousand for 90 days unlimited that's
why when you have cable
like the pay channels you see your
commercial 20 times the the real one CBS
ABC Fox when your show comes on at eight
o'clock [__] commercial comes on at 8
o'clock
[__] that's when you buy the whole bar
around
and if you see that commercial again at
8 35 give everybody a look
I just made like three thousand you
you put you on an a rotation so the
first commercial was 750. second one's a
thousand twelve 50 15. so if your
commercial hits four times in two hours
you made three thousand [__] dollars
and when it when they use the cycle it
starts all over again and also you're
getting checks from December 8th to
December 18th you made like sixty two
hundred dollars yeah you're like what
the [__] that's so badass I'm surprised
more comedians don't do that
they would get mad at him if he left
town like when he would work with Rogan
they'd call him up don't get on that
plane because they'd find them something
that's how good are you yeah it was
great there was maybe four people that
one year there's a black guy that books
all the commercials right the highest
paid commercial guy yeah Ari was like
number nine when yeah yeah
he booked the Kia commercial
first off let me give some [__]
things we get the [__] out of here on it
the best you understand me the best
today when I do those heavy kettlebell
workouts always a little [__] shroom
Tech on a little shroom tech support as
soon as I get in a little Hep protein a
little cocoa Two Scoops some water some
ice cubes maybe a banana for that put
some raspberries in that [__]
tremendous go to onyx.com right now look
at the great list of supplements that
they have from Alpha Brain a complete
money percent hundred percent money back
guarantee we don't want the product
complete has grown nootropic from Alpha
Brain to hemp Force protein all their
products are tremendous go to
honorrent.com right now and press in
church and get 10 off your first order
sent directly to your house if you want
them sent to your house on a monthly
level go on the stay on it program
they'll just keep sending you [__] every
[__] 30 days to your mailbox you
don't even have to leave the house you
don't have to go to Whole Foods anywhere
where they sell on it number two let me
explain something to you we all know how
sexy confidence can be right and that
confidence comes from being comfortable
how great you feel is underwear is
wrinkling around how good would you feel
right if you got underwear crippling up
your [__] rather if it's clumping on
me a nut sack me on these guests and
that's why they've created the world's
most comfortable [__] underwear for a
daily dose of confidence you wear
underwear every goddamn day 365 days a
year all right
you need to be extraordinary without an
insane price tag me undies understand it
and that's why they created the world's
most comfortable [__] underwear I
wear them when I [__] work out I hate
wearing underwear with jeans like going
commando okay but if I go to work out I
don't like my nutsack popping out of the
[__] shorts that that's a nightmare
out of my underwear meanders is the only
pair underwears that's controlled it's
their elastic is tremendous me undies is
made from Moto modal a fabric that's
twice as soft as cotton that's twice a
sauce whatever underwear you're wearing
right now so do me a favor right me and
this has tons of colors tons of styles
and the only place that you get a
matching for women and men they got a
great clothesline for women also it's
not just not for men and they even
released a new design every month they
sent me some new long underwears I might
have to [__] wear the Jiu Jitsu just
to [__] with these [__] I wear
the nice little camouflage underwear I
got the complete the black one so
there's no skid marks so listen we know
that shipping for pain paying for
shipping sucks so me and these has
removed that from the equation all
orders in the U.S and Canada they ship
for free so do me a favor go to Miami's
right now we're offering you 20 off your
first order of meandis.com Joey that's
right a special offer for my listeners
go to meanders.com Joey and get 20 off
and free shipping make sure you go to
meonies.com and get 20 off your first
order and tell them I sent you all right
who's better than me also to the best
people I know to Peter and David over at
nowthelife.com we got [__] up the
other night with those dabs they got
everything they got pipes they got
sticks to put the dab in they got gloves
to put onto the [__] things you can
hold on to the stick to put the dabs in
they have a tremendous vapor pen that's
what they just walk around with a torch
oh my God they walk around with porch
Edibles they got [__] everything go
to nail the life.com and press in enjoy
it is boom and get how much 20 off your
first order of the best [__] vapor
pen working today all right that's all I
got for you one more time another shout
out to me on these.com right now 20 off
from free shipping on it.com Joey get 10
off your first island.com church on
it.com church and get 10 off and you got
nailed in life
all right how about a little uh what do
you want to close it Elton John or oh
man or Band on the Run Band on the Run
there
you don't want to do uh
I'll see you guys next I'll see you guys
Sunday night listen I don't know what
you're doing Sunday night we're dropping
some Sid Aries coming by we're gonna
have celebrity guests coming in all
[__] night we got some chick coming
in we might be here for mate for like
three or four in the morning so get
ready for a long night if I was you I
wouldn't even going to work [__]
Monday calling sick gotta hit her ass
get some heroin we're gonna have a
[__] intercom thanks for having me
InterContinental show when there's a
special come on October 17th on few few
the gentleman Jerry Rocha check it out
thanks for having me bro I'm very proud
of you thanks for following my heart
thank you [__] it out you didn't go back
to Texas like the rest of these you
[__] got balls of steel thank you for
being a man of course thank you what's
up with you cop collector what are you
doing this weekend I I what I don't know
what I'm doing this weekend uh but I had
your buddy dearest you know my podcast
today very nice
no way I'm not going to be nowhere next
week I'm in Minneapolis the House of
Comedy on the 15th Thursday Friday
Saturday and the week after that I'm in
Fort Lauderdale Florida with dick Syed
we're going to hang out yeah oh we're
bringing stars of death we're doing
everything I'm getting I called the
chick yesterday she said I'll suck his
dick so we're gonna get your dad's Pizza
a little Cuban chick my dad and and a
nice Jewish guy and he he watches all
Joey's stuff so he calls me and he's
like I walked all Joey's stuff and I
want to talk to him about it but every
time I see him he gets me so messed up
on the Edibles I can't talk
sold you know
great you want a little bit of half no
I'll come
yeah
I love you guys see you Sunday night
eight o'clock 11 o'clock [__] East
Coast
debt